on this Sunday night a humiliating
defeat for the Kremlin
[Music]
Russia's Retreat and what's next and the
counter-offensive
two provinces two votes this week for
Premier a look ahead to Quebec's
election tomorrow and the UCP picks
Jason kenney's replacement for Alberta's
top job I had no family doctor otherwise
I could have gone to see them sound
familiar the new research painting a
grim picture for Primary Care in Canada
and driving the Auto Bond
[Music]
car made for the movies built in BC
global national with para Nasser
[Music]
good evening thank you for joining us
just 48 hours after Vladimir Putin stood
in front of a crowd at the Kremlin
formalizing the illegal annexation of
regions in Ukraine Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski announced a big
victory saying the symbolic Eastern town
of liman has been cleared of Russian
troops here's why it's important liman
is located in Donetsk that's one of the
four regions the Russian president
proclaimed to be part of his country on
Friday
it is a humiliating defeat for Russia
and strategically an important win for
Ukraine zielinski says there will be
more flags flying in the region in the
coming days but while this is a big blow
to the Kremlin as Sean O'Shea reports
the Ukrainian people are still facing a
russian-declared threat of nuclear war
it was a Ukrainian victory of no small
significance Russia suffered a
humiliating defeat as Ukrainian troops
took back the key city of Lehman
foreign
their territory after Russian soldiers
abandoned their positions a day earlier
Russian President Vladimir Putin had
declared this area now part of Russia
one of what he calls four new regions
instead Ukrainian soldiers removed
Russian flags and signs including one at
the local police station
Lehman isn't just any City it's been key
to the Russians during their occupation
of Ukraine absolutely it's significant
we're very encouraged by what we're
seeing right now Ukrainian troops had
encircled the city trapping Russian
soldiers inside before the Russians
finally retreated Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski praised his Army's
efforts
I thank our military and our Warrior
zielinski said glory to Ukraine but as
they celebrated
more signs the Russians attack on
civilians continues the Ukrainian
Security Service released this video it
said at least 20 were killed in an
attack on a convoy in eastern Ukraine in
late September one of those who died was
a pregnant woman Russia is also accused
of kidnapping the Ukrainian head of the
zapparesian nuclear facility the largest
in Europe his fate is not known
thank you
Vatican City Pope Francis urged a
Russian change of course
I renew my call for an immediate
ceasefire the pope said also asking
Ukraine to be open to a serious peace
Proposal with Russia threatening to use
nuclear weapons against Ukraine NATO's
Secretary General called the rhetoric
dangerous and for now that we provide
support to Ukraine an independent
Sovereign Nation in Europe that has the
right to defend itself against the war
aggression and this is right actually
enshrined in the U.N Charter and
therefore we will continue to provide
support to Ukraine to defend themselves
despite one important military Victory
ukrainians still have a long and likely
bloody fight ahead Channel Shea Global
News
leaks in the Nordstrom one and two
pipelines in the Baltic Sea have stopped
and could be restored explosions in the
Baltic Sea were the pipelines run were
recorded last Monday and although both
pipelines were not operational they were
still filled with gas the blast led to
leaks which the U.N says could be the
largest release of climate damaging
methane ever to be recorded North stream
one was once the largest supply of gas
from Russia to Europe it's unclear who
was responsible for the rupture but some
European countries have accused Russia
of sabotage
Indonesia is in mourning and the world
of soccer is in shock after 125 people
were killed in a match on Saturday night
this is a dark day for football
and the tragedy beyond comprehension
I extend my deepest condolences to the
families and friends of the victims
following a loss by the home team angry
fans stormed the pitch creating a
chaotic Stampede security at the stadium
used tear gas to try and disperse the
crowd a method of crowd control banned
by FIFA the sports governing body all
top league matches have been suspended
in the country until an investigation is
complete
foreign
[Applause]
on Sunday vigils were held for the
victims outside the stadium and also in
the capital of Jakarta teenagers and
children are among those who were killed
more than 300 others were injured those
who survived say they were lucky to
escape rights groups say the use of
excessive force by police in this case
cannot be justified
a top official in Iran is advocating a
harsher response to protesters there
today the country's parliamentary
speaker warned the growing protest could
destabilize the country's ruling
establishment he's urging Security
Forces to deal harshly with those who he
says endanger public order thousands of
Iranians have taken to the streets over
the last two weeks to protest the death
of Masa amini the 22-year-old woman had
been detained by Iran's so-called
morality police for allegedly not
adhering to Iran's strict dress code
following its second coup this year
Burkina faso's new military Junta is
urging calm after supporters attacked
the capital's French Embassy
fires were sparked and tear gas was
fired at protesters after the coup's
leadership claimed without evidence the
deposed president was hiding at a French
military base plotting a counter-attack
the military Junta now says the
situation is under control and asks
people to refrain from any acts of
violence against the embassy France has
denied any involvement in its former
colonies unrest
this week U.S President Joe Biden will
visit Puerto Rico and Florida to witness
the massive destruction that was caused
by recent hurricanes in Florida the
death toll has risen to 47 in the wake
of hurricane Ian which is now one of the
strongest storms to ever hit the United
States as Jennifer Johnson reports
evacuation efforts continue for
survivors cut off on Florida's Barrier
Islands
Coast Guard military and volunteer
helicopters are flying into the islands
off of Florida's Gulf Coast to rescue
thousands of stranded residents Bridges
connecting to the mainland were
destroyed by the hurricane homeowners
have gone several days without food
water power or shelter
[Applause]
hurricane Ian has become one of the
costliest storms in U.S history
President Joe Biden has pledged tens of
billions of dollars to help Floridians
and residents of the Carolinas rebuild
the president will view the devastation
in Florida Wednesday I'd like a little
help to get my home back in shape
because I have nowhere to go but
millions of Floridians now face the
daunting task of rebuilding without
flood insurance according to the
insurance information Institute only 18
percent of Florida's homes are covered
for flooding many of those who lived
inland even hundreds of kilometers from
where Ian hit like Orlando never
imagined they'd need it just to add a
lot of water but some of the rivers and
inlets overflowing so it's creating a
lot of problems really all across the
state the White House says Congress may
have to provide more emergency disaster
relief money for under or uninsured
Floridians right now the federal
government provides less than forty
thousand dollars for home repairs and
just under forty thousand for lost
properties we have limits in the amount
of money money that we can give and our
programs are designed to really help
jump start that recovery process
the death toll continues to rise most
from the Fort Myers region Lee County
officials reportedly didn't call for
evacuations until Tuesday morning
one day before Ian hit and at least a
full day after other counties told their
residents to get out but the city's
mayor says the county quote acted
appropriately thank God we're alive many
are thankful they survived this powerful
category 4 hurricane but so much work
and heartache lie ahead before lives and
livelihoods finally get back to normal
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
quebecers go to the polls this week
politicians in that Province have been
out on the hustings campaigning for 36
days and tomorrow voters will have their
say as our Quebec correspondent Mike
Armstrong explains the battle in this
race appears to be over who finishes
second
he's being a fairly comfortable albeit
at times bumpy campaign for Francois
Lego right out of the gate pollsters had
him far out in front it wasn't whether
he'd win it was by how much
there goes party the Coalition of near
Quebec the caq had a slim majority of
the 125 seats in Quebec's National
Assembly it looked like he'd be adding
to it considerably people at the
beginning of the campaign who said oh
the CQ could get like 105 seats
um I think that's probably uh overly
optimistic
the girl hasn't been able to build on
his lead this has not been a
particularly Clean Campaign there were
missteps by caq candidates like the
party's immigration Minister who said 80
percent of immigrants don't speak French
and don't work we go had to apologize
and there were missteps by the leader
himself Lego speaking about immigration
levels said in the last week of the
campaign accepting too many newcomers
would be quote a bit suicidal logo has
not been very disciplined I would say
this is not helping the the CQ to expand
its base
have going for him is a divided
opposition literally a four-way race for
second place the debates in this
campaign were crowded there are two
established parties the Liberals and the
parts between them they formed every
previous government for the last half
century and there are two newer parties
Quebec solidar and the fledgling Quebec
conservatives all four of them are going
into election day very nearly
statistically tied polls have them all
in the low to mid teens while support
for the caq has hovered in the high 30s
one party with a bit of an advantage in
the drive for a second maybe the
Liberals its support is more
concentrated than the others it remains
popular among anglophones and allophones
in the Montreal region things are going
well and you're going to see that later
you'll correct conservative party is
fighting its first campaign but its
support is more spread out and that may
not translate into any seats the leader
insists he's just happy with the
direction some people say you're far
away from power but we're far away from
where we were also a year ago so we're
quite happy but with the upswing
now francoiligo's popularity has taken a
hit since the first year of the pandemic
he was for an extended period the most
popular Premier in any Province he was
polling over 50 percent well much of
that has worn off Monday will answer the
question how much
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
and Alberta's United conservative party
members will choose a new leader this
week
UCP members have been voting since late
August on who should replace Premier
Jason Kenney he resigned in May you'll
remember after narrowly surviving a
leadership review the winner of the race
to replace him will be announced on
Thursday
Brazilians headed to the polls as their
country's presidential election got
underway today but contention is already
Brewing over the possible results
prior opinions polls show that former
president Lula de Silva has a solid
chance to win against polarizing
right-wing incumbent J.R bolsonaro
however bolsonaro earlier signaled that
he will refuse a potential defeat making
baseless claims of voter fraud and
election authorities working against him
tensions across the country were already
high leading up to the vote with
numerous cases of violent and even fatal
attacks on both candidates supporters
thank you
and in Bulgaria it's deja vu for voters
and their fourth national election
within just two years it was triggered
after its incumbent reformist
government's Coalition collapsed initial
results show the center-right gerb party
will win the election that saw low voter
turnout but they must form yet another
fragile Coalition with several other
parties to maintain government the EU
nation is struggling with an economic
crisis and its complicated ties to
Russia following the invasion of Ukraine
coming up the great Exodus of family
doctors the burden on patients and the
Health Care system
it's no secret that finding a family
doctor these days can be frustrating but
since the start of the pandemic
retaining one is proving to be difficult
as well for many Canadians with a rising
number of professionals leaving the
practice and as Karen Lieberman explains
the worrying impact of the shortage
isn't on the patient only it's also on
the system
I can't walk and I'm in constant pain
and I had no family doctor otherwise I
could have gone to see them when Donna
kvanch lost her business during the
pandemic she turned to Bar management to
pay the bills but an accident has left
her unable to work and needing care as I
just started to change the cake the
entire cake exploded hitting me in the
left ear damaging my hearing my balance
I'm in constant pain kavenge turned to
her family doctor but learned he had
died at the onset of covid-19 and there
was no one to replace him anybody who
has any sort of health issues whether
they've been ongoing or just new if you
don't have a family doctor there's
nowhere for you to go going into the
pandemic recent data showed 1.8 million
ontarians were already without a family
doctor and new research paints an even
more somber Outlook about three percent
of family physicians in Ontario that's
385 out of 12 000 stop practicing
between March and September 2020
according to the study and while that
doesn't sound like a lot it accounted
for 170
000 patients losing access to Primary
Care those who stopped working were more
likely to be 75 or older practiced in a
traditional fee for service model care
for under 500 patients and work less
than other Physicians and many were
approaching retirement and accelerated
their plans we found twice as many
family doctors stopped working during
the pandemic than we would have expected
if Family Medicine is the front door to
the Health Care System what happens when
that door is closed for kavenge it meant
repeated visits to a local walk-in
clinic and er if I would have had a
family doctor then perhaps on that
Monday I would have been at their office
and I wouldn't be in the predicament
onion now when you don't have a family
doctor it means you don't really have a
trusted place where you can go to get
the care you need so you end up trying
to get care from other places other
areas that are already stretched thin
Karen Lieberman Global News
ahead there's another labor shortage
Quebec parents know all about when the
wheels on the bus stop
you're watching global national
[Music]
in Montreal the start of the school year
has become problematic for many students
before they even set foot in the
classroom school buses are often getting
canceled last minute because of a
shortage of drivers as Phil Carpenter
reports bus operators and Educators fear
there's no quick and easy answer to get
the commute rolling smoothly again
these were selling kids are some of the
lucky ones they had a school bus Friday
morning
very often these days though many
Montreal era kids don't have one on a
daily basis we notice we're missing two
or three of those bus drivers so that
means there are probably about 100 150
kids that are not going to be able to
get to school or get picked up
she points out there's a shortage of
drivers for school buses that's much
worse at this school year it's not just
in Quebec it's right across Canada the
states and even in Europe some parents
on Montreal's South Shore say there the
school year started out just fine within
two weeks however buses stopped coming
now we've had two weeks of no morning
bus except for one time they had a
replacement for the morning sometimes
it's the appearance they only find out
hours before a scheduled pickup that
there won't be a bus I think for special
needs and adapted Transit it's been a
lot harder in some places the bus just
doesn't show up school bus companies say
they haven't seen it this bad owner
Andrew Jones says he's lucky so far
they've been able to service all their
routes but we're only able to because
I'm on the road my mechanics on the road
my dispatcher's on the road the main
reason for the shortage he says the pay
twenty dollars an hour and working
conditions aren't competitive enough I
had two interviews scheduled at 10 and
11 and both were no-shows and when you
contact them back they say you know what
I found better you would kind of offer
me enough pay the owner believes that
pay needs to improve and the six to
eight weeks it takes a driver to get a
license is too long he can't think of a
short-term solution meanwhile he and
school officials are asking for patience
be kind to uh be kind to your bus driver
Phil Carpenter Global News Montreal
from British Columbia with love next the
Canadian Recreation of James Bond's
vehicle of choice
foreign
[Applause]
a 23 year old woman has become the
youngest ever to win the London marathon
and that's despite her taking a nasty
fall over a speed bump that injured her
hip her hand and her knee the fall
itself had set her back 25 meters from
the front of the pack but she persevered
and she ran the last mile of the race in
four minutes and 43 seconds and the
Ethiopian Runner isn't finished yet her
next goal is to break the world record
well speaking of speed is probably one
of the most famous cars in spy movie
history James Bond's Aston Martin DB5
can do just about anything whether it
was firing Gatling guns or being fitted
with its own ejection seat Well now one
BC man has been on a mission to create a
perfect replica of the vehicle right
down to the double O agents gadgets Jay
Durant has more
maybe consider it the most iconic car of
all time James Bond's Aston Martin DB5
my modified the front have the oil and
Olivier spilborgs has built one from
scratch complete with all the working
gadgets from the Gatling guns at the
front that's just in no time to Die the
smoke screen coming out the back most
people think I'm crazy to spend that
much time and and uh the amount of work
you know probably I don't know six seven
thousand hours this is the car that was
in Goldfinger and Thunderball he was
inspired by the bond car that used to be
displayed at Frank Baker's the Attic
restaurant in west Vancouver where his
parents would take him as a kid this is
one of the original promotional cars
used for the bond franchise what a
thrill this is gonna be
it was a big deal it was on the news it
was it was in the papers it was like you
know a celebrity had come into Vancouver
Frank Baker's old car was now at a
museum in the Netherlands and
Spielberg's tracked it down so he could
see it up close one more time after all
these years I think the lady in there
thought I was pretty weird because I was
hanging around the one car for probably
most of the day taking photos this is
the tire slasher with the support of
family and friends his longtime passion
project is nearing the end Spielberg
started this in 2013 after first
building a prototype the finished
running model is almost complete another
Gadget that I gotta work on that I'm
going to do over the winter is the oil
sprayer
foreign
once word starts getting out there could
be a lot of calls coming in from car
shows hoping to book a spot for his
prize ride I love the fact that
everything works on this and then maybe
Olivier might start thinking about his
next big project I actually get my
satisfaction from reaction so when I
build stuff and somebody just loves it
or you know goes crazy over it and they
enjoy it that's that's my paycheck
[Music]
and that's global national for this
Sunday night I'm Farah Nasser on behalf
of our crew thanks for spending time
with us tonight's your Canada is Little
Pond Prince Edward Island Dan will be
back with you tomorrow until next time
take care of yourselves and each other
good night
foreign
[Music]